تصعيد اخر على جبهه اخرى بين موسكو واشنطن
جهاز الامن الاتحادي الروسي يعتقل صحفيا
امريكيا من اصل روسي يعمل مراسلا لصحيفه
اما التهمه فهي الاشتباه في قيامه بالتجسس
لمصلحه واشنطن
الامن الروسي قال ان ايفان جريش كوفيتش
كان مكلفا من امريكا بجمع معلومات عن
انشطه احدى المؤسسات الدفاعيه غير ان بيان
جهاز الامن الروسي لم يقدم دليلا على
الاتهامات
صحيفه وولز جورن نفت ما وصفتها بالمزاعم
الروسيه الموجهه لمراسلها واكدت انها تسعى
لاطلاق سراحه فورا
لكن الخارجيه الروسيه التي تعترف
بجرشكوفيتش مراسلا معتمدا في روسيا قالت
انما كان يفعله لا علاقه له بالصحافه
الكريم من جانبه قال ايضا ان مراسل وولز
ضبط متلبسا بالتجسس وملفه بيد الامن
الفيدرالي
موسكو استبعدت اي تبادل لجيرش كوفيتش مع
واشنطن واكدت ان ذلك ليس على جدول اعمالها
ولن يحدث ذلك قبل محاكمته جرش كوفيتش اول
صحفي امريكي يقبض عليه في روسيا بتهمه
التجسس منذ الحرب البارده وابرز شخصيه
امريكيه تعتقلها روسيا بعد نجمه كره السله
العام الماضي حيث قبض عليها في مطار موسكو
وبحوزتها زيت الحشيش اطلق سراحها في صفقه
لتبادل السجناء بين البلدين في ديسمبر
الماضي